cinquième jour d'offensive donc russe en
ukraine l'ukraine qui affirme que moscou
a ralenti le rythme de l'offensive alors
que des pourparlers doivent se tenir à
la frontière entre l'ukraine et la
biélorussie dans la région de tchernobyl
est la délégation ukrainienne et est
arrivée sur place elle devrait relayer
la position du président ukrainien et
lenski qui demande un cessez le feu
immédiat et le retrait des forces russes
d'ukraine je vous propose d'écouter tout
de suite le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky
oui nous appelons l'union européenne à
accélérer l'adhésion immédiate de
l'ukraine via une procédure spéciale
mais nous sommes reconnaissants envers
nos partenaires d'être avec nous mais
notre objectif est d'être avec tous les
européens et surtout d'être égaux